foreign
[Music]
let's get started folks with another
speedrun game for those watching on
YouTube I am currently in Oslo Norway
comments hitting the chesket cup uh so
apologies in advance for uh any audio or
video problems but hopefully things hold
up and we are playing Black against anik
0506 and as is our custom we will
attempt an accelerate a dragon and
finally we get an open Sicilian which
has been rare uh in the speed run uh
thus far we actually have had just a
handful of accelerated dragons let's see
how it holds up against a strong player
and this is our first marozzi bind this
is very exciting we have not faced the
marozzi bind to date
at a lower level it's much more common
to play Knight to C3 which is sort of
the other main move the marozzi binds
which is characterized by the pawns on
e4 and C4 this is a classic bind and in
general in chess a bind is a situation
where two or more pawns control a set of
key Central squares in this case they
really only control one square the D5
square but the the danger of this
positionally is that it is very very
hard for black to break free in the
center with D5 and so if black handles
this opening improperly what often
happens is that Black's position becomes
incredibly crimped so it's not like
white is trying to Checkmate us the
morosi bind is dangerous from a
positional standpoint because handled
improperly you get a situation where
black just runs out of ideas and is
basically you know hanging around on the
bottom two or three ranks
so the line that I recommend against the
marozzi is not the most popular Bishop
G7 it's actually to start with the move
Knight to F6
now of course the appeal of this move is
that it hits the E4 Pawn straight away I
think our opponent already responds uh
with a somewhat improper move F3 instead
the the common response series Knight B1
to C3 which I'll address separately
after the game and I'll kind of give you
the outline of this system that I
recommend so I think we can basically do
the same thing against the move F3
what you want to do here is actually
take on D4 so you invite White's Queen
to recapture and it may seem at first
sight that this can only benefit white
why is that well it's because the queen
on D4 looks unassailable but what you
should realize what you should realize
oh apparently I've lost to this guy oh
it's the guy I disconnected against
that's funny so there was a speedrun
game for those watching on YouTube where
I got Auto disconnected and then it auto
auto resigned then it was against this
guy
do I have my chance at Revenge
but what you should notice is that once
the bishop is deployed to the long
diagonal the queen is going to be under
very serious fire and there's going to
be threats of a discovered attack with
this Knight but we don't want to go
Bishop G7 immediately because we we
don't want to give white the opportunity
to play E5 because that'll Force our
Knight back to G8 and why should we
allow that kind of stuff right
although on the other hand after Bishop
G7 E5 Knight G8 white is so poorly
developed that that E5 font is going to
be very hard to hold so I actually think
that we can start with Bishop G7 this is
a very tricky move
and my intuition tells me that after E5
Knight GA which is what happens on the
board white is going to be unable to
hold on to his Center without that
Center starting to collapse
so who can tell me
what is the best way of attacking this
E5 Pawn using the pin against White's
Queen that's kind of the key element of
this position is that pin which allows
us to put pressure on weight Center of
course it's the obvious D6 which is what
we should start with
Bishop F4 okay I don't think this is the
area I think our opponent is is doing
what he did in our previous game which
is just playing instantly and and
you know kind of bluffing
so let's think here for a second
now of course we have the option of
playing Pawn takes Pawn then a queen
trade is forced but then white will
Castle Queen side with check and develop
an initiative in the end game in that
position it looks like White's got
pretty decent compensation for the pawn
so that's a backup option
now of course we have the option of
developing the Knight to H6 and trying
to Castle quickly but that's a bit
anti-climactic is our general strategy
is to put pressure on this E5 plot yeah
there is this very interesting move some
of you are suggesting which is to play
Queen to A5 and the idea is to not only
pin the Knight but more to the point is
the fact that it attacks the e51 it
threatens a fork but after Queen A5
white has the very annoying move Queen
to D5
and that's a hard move for us to deal
with because in the event of the queen
trade white will be threatening Knight
C7
so after Queen A5 Queen D5 we can try to
drop our Queen back to B6 not a bad
option but again white has this check on
B5 forcing the Queens off the board and
again we're experiencing problems where
the Knight always threatens to get to
the C7 Square so
it's actually quite tricky to play this
position
I'm also looking at some developing
moves here we don't actually have to
make a move to attack this Pawn we can
play a simple move like Bishop E6
so I actually think that that is the
most practical option rather than trying
to do everything in one move we can just
bring our freaking pieces out
so Bishop B6 is possible
and then in the event the White Castle's
Queen side then we can play Pawn takes
E5 and in contrast to the immediate Pawn
takes E5 notice that our Rook is going
to be protecting our Queen so this is
the kind of move which I think a lot of
lowering players would find it very
difficult to make because we're not
attacking E5 we're not doing what what
one might think we have to do and
instead we're just kind of keeping the
tension and making a regular developing
move and I actually can't believe our
opponent is thinking clearly I'm doing
something right then I'm also not saying
that it's the best move it might not be
the best move
now you might also wonder well wait a
second why are we not putting our Bishop
on the quote-unquote more aggressive F5
Square now Bishop F5 does not prevent
long castles because by rule it's the
king that cannot cross a defendant
Square The Rook is allowed to cross a
defended Square so in response to Bishop
F5 white could indeed Castle Queen side
what I like about Bishop E6 though is
that it does pressure the C4 Pawn which
could become important later and the
second thing it does is it controls the
D5 Square which is a rather annoying
jumping off point for white snide in
certain variations
foreign so I think that we're in pretty
good shape here in retrospect maybe was
not the best idea to allow E5 the
classic treatment is to play D6 in order
to prevent E5 so after Knight C3 which
is the main move after takes takes
you're supposed to play D6 there it's
actually very important in that
particular version to not allow E5 the
difference here is that white didn't use
this move to develop a piece so I in you
know I concluded that we can get away
with allowing E5
so what are we threatening okay Queen E4
that's a good move
it's a great move
now we can start to play tactically here
and I have a very exciting idea
now we shouldn't fall asleep because
what is the point of Queen E4 well it
defends B7 so some of you might be
thinking oh well let's defend the pawn
with something like Rook B8 well that
would be a very very bad move because
white is now able
to take on D6 why does that favor white
because you might say oh but that
doesn't that open up our Bishop well if
you look more carefully after e d e d
the pros the cons outweigh the pros
because that D6 Pawn becomes an
incredibly vulnerable weakness and a
white can Castle Queen side there and
immediately the D6 Pawn collapses and
our King is going to stay stranded in
the center so let's not touch that with
a 10 foot pole which gives us
essentially one option I don't like
Queen B6 here because that actually
invites white to Castle queenside right
it invites white to do what he wants to
do anyway so I actually think we have to
take on E5 and and resolve the tension
in the center that's going to help us
develop our King side more quickly
Bishop takes E5 now we've got two
options the first is the sort of mundane
option which equalizes the second is the
nariditsky approach and it's very much
in the spirit of the accelerated Dragon
might be dubious subjectively but I
think we can make it work so the simple
option is to trade on E5
and then play Knight G8 to F6 and then
to Castle King side in that position is
I think approximately equal
the second option let's see who can come
up with it what else is available to us
in this position
actually we have a third option which
might be even better
yeah a lot of you guys are finding it
it's not F5 because F5 is a very
weakening move that would be one movitus
the queen just drops back and what have
we achieved right we've merely deprived
this bishop of a very important Defender
but in the same Spirit the move that I
missed initially was Bishop to F5
Bishop to F5
oh but White's got a sick tactic there
oh my gosh white can take on B7 there
after Bishop takes Bishop
drop the queen back to B5 and then win
the bishop back on E5 with an extra pawn
and I am not getting lucky in the speed
run now we can go for that line
consciously because it accelerates our
development
but in the same Spirit we can also
simply play Knight F6 Queen takes B7 and
castle kingside and try to develop uh
development advantage and then somehow
punish Wade for keeping the king in the
Senate
so let me think about which option is
better
yeah it feels like I did something wrong
here
I have been getting very consistently
outplayed in the speedrun in the last
couple of games it seems
but let's not panic it might be
necessary for us to play Bishop takes E5
Queen takes C5 and Knight F6
and this is something that you know that
that constitutes an important skill at a
higher level as well which is to
basically admit yeah I it's not that I
messed up I don't think I messed up
seriously but I didn't want to go for
this line initially because it's boring
and because giving away your fiancato
Bishop can be a problem now it should be
pointed out that if we compare the
placement of the remaining Bishops our
Bishop is definitely better than its
counterpart and the reason I say that is
because of this C4 Pawn which is really
blunting this bishop on F1 on the other
hand White's got an active Queen whites
got slightly better control of the
center so this Pawn can be considered
both the strength and a weakness which
is very common at a higher level
and of course also this Pawn on F3 is
not the pawn itself is not a weakness
but of course as I've pointed out many
times when there's a pawn like this on
F3 or on F4 you always have this idea of
playing Queen to B6 and in general
exploiting this diagonal when White
Castle short H4 so our opponent kind of
going for the kill here I'm not scared
of this move because white doesn't have
any development here so this just cannot
work from a perspective of Chess
principles but we we should take this
idea seriously well we've got again
several options we can play H5 which
would be the move that we play if we
respect our opponent's idea
alternatively we could just Castle in
White's face and allow H5
it's not entirely a paper tiger like
this could get very dangerous for us
but I I'm just very scary I mean it's
hard to refute our opponent's play
we could then just play Queen C6 and
trade queens and try to win the end game
that would be an option actually I don't
dislike that option let's start by
castling so let's start by completing
our development there's no way that H5
directly leads to Checkmate I called BS
on that
okay so what are our options here well
we can play Knight takes H5 and that's a
hard move to evaluate definitely we
don't get mated right away after Knight
takes H5 what worries me about that move
is that is the long-term problems along
the H file but I did just come up with a
cool defensive idea so what is white
likely to do after Knight takes H5 well
I think the obvious move there is G4 but
after G4 we drop our Knight back to F6
and we ask well why does white really
achieved from sacrificing that pawn the
queen could then drop back to H2 but the
H7 Pawn would be very well protected by
our Knight
and that in general would not be a scary
type of idea I think that we should call
BS on this and take this pod fearlessly
I don't see a clear follow-up for white
I just don't see it
maybe something exists
but I do not see it
well if he takes the Knight then we take
it back and I don't see a follow-up
there either I don't think there's
checkmate
our opponent is probably going to opt
for something like that that would be
consistent with what he's been doing
but I'm kind of calling the bluff here
yeah so maybe there's some sort of
hidden tactic I don't I don't rule that
out at all again entirely possible that
there's some Perpetual there or there's
some line that that leads to a strong
attack but our opponent doesn't go for
it and this was my idea so this is the
move that initially caused me to rule
out uh Knight takes H5 but I think
there's a brilliant defensive move in
this position how do you find this
defensive move well you should always
have a wish list in mind and I've talked
about this before what are the items
that you want to achieve to further the
causes of your position I think the top
item on the wish list and this should be
obvious to everybody is a queen trade
right if we can trade Queens then we're
simply up upon in the end game the
moment you tell yourself that this move
should become maybe not obvious but you
should at least should be on your radar
and that's Queen d8 to B8
which is not hard to see conceptually
right there's different types of
difficulty in chess there's conceptual
difficulty where a move might be easy to
see but it might be hard to understand
why it's good this is the kind of move
that when it's played everybody says ah
well of course Queen B8 but it can be
hard to see geometrically right because
you're just no you don't make this move
often and a lot of you might have been
tempted by a move like Queen to B6 which
I think would have been incredibly
dangerous
the additional benefit of this move is
that if white declines the queen trade
with Queen to G5
how should we proceed in that position
this is the sort of second part of our
idea
insisting on your concept
Queen G3 exactly Queen G3 now Queen F4
would be a blunder there because of Rook
takes H5 grabbing the Knight and
protecting the queen at the same time a
very very common type of blunder
but in the same vein Queen G5 Queen G3
check forces the queens and after our
Knight gets to G3 don't stop calculating
there notice the white experiences
problems with this spawn on C4 because
we will be then threatening to take on
F1 and take on C4 with two extra Pawn
now you might say well why can move Rook
H4 in that position that's some high
level calculation but you don't have to
calculate any further because we know
for a fact that we are up a pawn and
we're chilling in that position
so if white plays rookie H5 now then we
will take back on H5
white has a check on G5 but after King
h8 I don't see a follow-up and it occurs
to me now that white did have a draw in
the previous position white could have
drawn the game here by force with a very
very Advanced uh tactical concept which
I'll show you after the game but it did
in fact start with the Rook takes H5
so at this point I think we're very much
in control of the game
and that is obviously a good sign now
that doesn't mean we've won we're just
up upon
but we're up upon and we still have the
advantage of our Superior Bishop our
Knight on H5 suddenly becomes an asset
rather than a deficiency because it's
threatening to jump onto one of these
weak dark squares and it's just nicely
played I mean it could come back to F6
at any time and kind of rejoin Society
but it's it's doing well on this little
island here
and our Bishop is also doing a great job
because it's taking the sting out of the
move Knight to D5 which would now be
simply Bishop takes D5
so again to convert such end games which
is one of the hardest skills in chess
one you should never feel bad when you
fail to convert an end game like this
right where you're let's say apple Pawn
because it's it's genuinely very very
difficult and white has some assets too
I mean his pieces are active he's got a
pawn majority it's just we've got an
extra Pawn on the other side of the
board so this requires tremendous
Precision I'm going to accelerate a
little bit here because we're kind of
low on time now
broadly speaking of course we want to
trade pieces right that's a pretty
straightforward statement we want to
trade pieces if we can get all of the
Rooks off the board I think it'll be
easier for us
to sort of convert our four on two
Pawn majority on the king side
so there's a couple of ideas here we can
throw the Knight onto G3 that's one
option but then white will play Bishop
D3 the Knight could potentially be
maneuvered back to F5 but I'm not
totally convinced that the trade of
Bishop for Knight is positive for us I
think that we should make a less
committal move and just play Rook fd8 I
think we should keep our our Trump cards
in our pocket and keep the Knight on H5
and we should get a pair of Rooks off
the board now the downside of this
approach is that we've given up the D
file but if you look more carefully this
bishop is really a hero because it's
holding this penetration Square on D7
yeah why does the D file but I don't
think the white has a lot that he can
gain from the control over the D file
now we can do a couple of different
things
in general our opponent's plan is
probably to start pushing his Pawn
majority with something like C5 so a
move that occurs to me as a kind of
prophylactic measure is to play B6 and
try to Halt the progress of the pawn
alternatively Rook C8 comes to mind but
that's a little bit passive we can still
play Knight G3 probably white will play
Bishop D3 there
and maybe in that position
we can already consider Knight F5
although again I'm not totally sure who
benefits with that trade I think it
might be us though yeah I'm I'm inclined
to play Knight G3 I think now is the
time to
um reap the rewards of our night and I
think that we should play Knight F5
and essentially ask quite a question
okay our opponent is answering questions
very quickly in this game now we have a
bishop versus night position what
changed my mind is that we've traded a
pair of Rooks I think with only one pair
of Rooks on the board White's rook and
Knight look very impressive but again
all that white can really do here is
pose one move threats and that's what
our opponent is doing
obviously we drop our Bishop back to E6
there's no other squares in Knight T5
okay so that asks us a big question do
we want to trade Bishop for Knight and
your answer should not just be yes
uncritically because after Bishop takes
Knight Rook takes Bishop what's the
complicating factor in that Rook end
game well it's the fact that white is
infiltrating the seventh Rank by force
which is a big deal but upon closer
examination I think that we can actually
keep the Rook away from the seventh rank
how by playing what move King f8 there
and if white still drops The Rook on the
seventh rank what's our strategy there
what's our defensive strategy
so Bishop takes D5 Rook takes D5 King f8
Rook D7 we go King E8
Rook C7 King d8 and we drive The Rook
out of that seventh Rank and that should
already be winning so I think we should
take maybe our opponent will take that
no okay and we should go King f8
now our more broadly what we want to do
is go King E8 and then trade the Rooks I
mean the Pod end games are going to be
winning most of them although if you've
watched my pod ending videos you will
know that there is a complicating Factor
on the king side unfortunately what is
it what can white do to try to make it
difficult for us to exploit our Pawn
majority what moves can white
potentially make at some point
yeah so I can do what's called The Deep
Freeze and that's where one pawn stops
two or more pawns from advancing and
this is the most common type of deep
freeze a very Advanced move G5 not easy
to make because you have to understand
why you're making it and you're making
it to Halt the progress of the H Pawn H5
then of course meets with on Passat so
even some of those Pawn end games and I
have some examples you could have a pawn
end game where you're up to even two or
even three pawns but because there's a
deep freeze situation the pawn majority
on the other flank decides the game so
we shouldn't just uncritically go for
that Rook end game now deep freezes can
be fought right this G5 Pawn could be
contested with a timely F6 but then
white could play F4 so we'll have to
calculate Pawn end games concretely so
given the opportunity we might actually
want to play H6 so that if white ever
plays G5 well we take the sting out of
it and we can actually play that now
but we could also go King E8 so what's
more important
well it's hard to say that requires some
calculation over everything as Canty
says
now my temptation
is to bring our King into the game
yeah I think we should do that I think
we should start with King E8
and I'm really not sure okay now we can
Again Play H6
and and hold off the pawn majority we
could play E6 and Chase The Rook away
that's an interesting option we could
play Rook d8 but I can't I'm not
convinced that that pawn and game is
winning because of this G5 idea which is
quite annoying so definitely we
shouldn't hurry I think we should play
H6 but oh but then we can go Rook T1 and
Rook H1 wow
that's nuts
so maybe F6 is a better way to do the
same thing
maybe F6 is an interesting approach here
man this is not easy
E6 is possible as well
Rook D1 King E7 Rook H1 Rook H5 and
white deep freezes us again
but then we play E5 no I think that that
one's winning oh so E6 is a very good
looking move
yeah I think we should go E6 and just
get this Rook off of D5 this also forces
white to kind of decide where he wants
to keep the Rook because if he keeps it
on the fifth rank then potentially he
gives us the D file so asking questions
like these is always a good idea now I
have a higher level plan in mind here's
the ideal scenario again it's the sort
of wish list method where you say okay
what do I want to achieve in the ideal
scenario well ideally we want one of two
things either we want a pawn end game
where we don't have a deep freeze
situation so in some way we've prevented
G5 that would be winning because the
four on two Pawn majority will beat the
three on two Pawn majority on the other
side but the second wish list item is a
situation where we create a past age
pawn and get this ba Rook over to h8
that would basically end the game right
away those types of situations are
almost always winning in Rook end games
and I'll show you kind of a stock
example of that after the game there's a
famous classical game that really shows
the extent to which that situation often
decides the game in a rook end game
so after Rook to D1 you would be
forgiven for thinking that we should
play H5 let's go let's create the passer
but if you calculate after ghgh Rook H1
The Rook can't jump over the king that
is why after Rook D1 we have to go King
E7
if after that white plays Rook H1 and
hits the H7 Pawn we are just in time to
play Rook to h8 and what do we threaten
after we play Rook age
and what do you think white should do in
response to that just testing your
understanding
okay Rook B5 the move there uh was of
course H5 right so once we play Rook h a
we're ready to play H5 our opponent is
taking a fundamentally different
approach he is trying to hold off them
of H5 and I think this is the best move
okay so let's think
again we have options I think here we
should take the opportunity to play H6
this is the time that we should play H6
the reason why is that if instead you
play a move like King to D7 and maybe we
should have played A6 over now that I
think about it yeah maybe A6 is better
but it doesn't really matter the thing
is white was threatening to play G5
there
now I think we're in great shape
but we have to be extremely precise this
guy's
wildly wildly underrated let's see
I think that we should go King E7
but I'm not sure
well we have to bring our thing up right
some way
because if we give or check on DNA we we
simply help white skin get closer to our
side of the territory
so the ultimate Choice here is between
King D7 and King E7
and my intuition tells me that we should
stay a little bit closer to our King
side pawns now we're very very close to
being able to create a passer either
with H5
and in order to be able to play H5 we're
going to have to kick this Rook off the
fifth rank so in our pocket we have this
move A6 which we can throw in
essentially when we're ready to play H5
which is now
but white is very active here so there
are some complicating factors the king
is Super Active
of course The Rook is pressuring B7 and
we want to be careful about playing B6 I
mean maybe that was the best movements
actually that was the best move wasn't
it should have played B6 simply
for some reason I thought C5 was a
problem but it's not because BC is a
check it's late I'm missing I'm missing
some details in this end game but I
still think we're winning
yeah but our opponent
this guy is incredibly Sharp
incredibly sharp he punishes us for not
playing V6
but it's not the end of the world far
from the end of the world
that we have a choice here because C6 is
not a serious threat actually C6 is not
a threat at all
not a threat at all
so we have options we can play F6 which
is an ugly looking move but the benefit
of F6 why would we do that well it would
be to prevent White's King from
infiltrating E5
we can also play Rook da Rook D7 and
essentially shift the positioning of our
Rook so that in addition to defending B7
it is also doing something productive
and keeping White's King away
I think there are multiple ways to win
here
um
I really like the look of Rook deed and
Rook D7
I also like the look of H5 basically not
procrastinating but then if a rook gets
stuck here that might be an issue
because eventually we'll need to go like
King D7 King C6 to get that Rook behind
the pod
so man this is really hard
okay let's go Rook d8 track this is this
is what my intuition tells me to do
H5 might be committing a little too
early I agree but these are you know
this hopefully if you're newer to chess
you're beginning to see through the lens
of this end game why Rook end games are
considered like so complex and hard to
learn it's because in the middle game
the position you have these things that
you can hold on to to make sense of the
position in Rook end games it's so like
there's always like five or seven
candidate moves and all of them look
reasonable and all of them adhere to
different plans like do you start by
creating a passer do you improve the
position of the Rook do you improve your
Pawn structure on the king side there's
so many things that you can do and all
of them seem approximately equivalent
and very often there's only one winning
path so you're essentially relying in
most cases purely on your intuition and
on a little bit of calculation and most
of the calculation that you do in Rook
end games it involves figuring out who
wins if you get into a pawn in game
that's called liquidation and it's
sometimes calculating Pawn races and
concrete things like that
so Rook end games are incredibly hard
almost nobody can play them without even
without mistakes Magnus
definitely the best Rook end game player
of all time capablanca was well known
for that as well so it's very very hard
to play without blundering
I'll give you some recommendations on
end games after the game but here I have
to focus because two and a half minutes
is not a lot of time
okay so we could play F5 check see again
we could play this move or we could not
play this move I don't think there's a
hurry to play F5 because we could always
play it on the next move again white
cannot deep freeze us anymore because we
played this move H6
so broadly our plan is now to exploit
our Pawn majority F4 so white is trying
to go G5 here so we shouldn't fall
asleep although G5 could be met with H5
but I still don't like that scenario
because then our remaining three pawns
are gonna be essentially immobilized
so I like the look of F5 check
but then white takes it we take back
white drops back because white does get
mated after King E5 Rook D5
and then we can go King F6 and we've
made some progress and we're ready to
push the H Pawn
and that's one option
we could also start with H5 or we could
play King F6 and use our King to kind of
Shield ourselves from these pawns but
King F6 is quite unwieldy because we
essentially put our King in front of our
own pawns let's break through with F5 I
think this is our chance to do it
you are upon him finding all the tricky
lines here and stake with the G Pawn of
course King E5 Rook D5 is Checkmate so
white has to drop back and then I think
we need to make one more move before we
are ready to start pushing the h-bot
this might be a drop I mean we're
basically playing at this point for two
results which is really a pleasant
feeling
but still I mean if white defends this
accurately I think you should be able to
draw this yeah King F6 and King F6 is a
pretty intuitive move for experienced
end game players there are several ideas
of this move one of them is finally to
open up the pathway for The Rook to drop
to H7 which is the best Square on the
board this is why you know your Rook can
make or break your endgame experience
because on a square like H7 it's both
attacking and defending at the same time
the second thing that we should consider
doing is pushing while we have a chance
because here's the thing after H5 Ting
F3 H4 our pod is itself cutting off
White's King from its ability to stop
that pawn by stepping in front of it so
why if you'd go King G2 Rook H7 King H3
but then perhaps we create a second pass
Pawn with E5 so we want to make this
move E5 but we want to do it at a
strategic moment so I think we should
start oops sorry by pushing H5
drive this Pawn up as far as it'll go
put the Rook behind it or maybe play E5
on the next move or something like that
but E5 is not going anywhere for the
time being
I think White's best move and this is an
incredibly Advanced move is actually
King F2
okay
let's think about this H4 King G2
sorry so much calculation to do here
H4 King G2
oh
E5 character needs three
or we cut him off I should be winning
here
should be winning here I think
we should go H4
he's probably gonna go King G2
and that then I think we should go E5 I
think that's the ripe moment to play E5
now he goes Rook H3 if that should be a
mistake now we have a check on D2 here
oh but he's out calculated me
we can also go Rook H7 by the way which
is a backup option Rook D2 King E3 takes
picture it takes there there there
that might be a draw actually so I think
man
I missed a detail there that I'll show
you after the game let's go Rook H7
let's go Rook H7
and try to try to put the Rook behind
upon me that's the obvious move Rook H7
is obvious of course there was also
rookie two check which is what I was
relying on I don't think it works again
I'm making these judgments fully
intuitively
yeah I don't know this guy is 24 20. I
mean he's I am I would say he's I am
strength or maybe FM strength
I mean I'm not playing perfectly but
yeah he's very very strong
but legit I mean I think he is legit I
just think he's extremely underrated
no I won't flag I mean I might not win
this game but I won't flag and now we
play five so again this was the last
chance for us to get on the train
because if White had been able to go
King D4 then we wouldn't have been able
to play E5 so we can't miss that
opportunity it should be winning for
black I mean definitely the position is
winning can I convert it with a minute
on my clock
now what is it that we want to achieve
here well what we want to achieve
broadly is we want to force this Rook to
move because every time we force The
Rook to move our Pawn is able to advance
one square further and Tie The Rook down
even further ultimately we want a
situation where the pawn reaches H2 and
White's Rook is relegated to H1
when that scenario occurs we can
basically use that pawn as a bargaining
chip give it away but give it away in
order to transition to a pawn in game
this is the standard technique for
winning such positions where the Rook is
behind the pawn and then in the
resulting scenario White's King is going
to be you know in Timbuktu and we're
gonna Converge on these three pawns with
our own King
sounds very complicated but I'll show
you once I start showing you this
technique after the game you'll
understand immediately what what I'm
talking about
now what are the complicating factors
here well the issue is that white is not
obliged to move the Rook from H3 why
does other moves white is not in the
zugsvang in other words why does two
types of moves that he can make white
can try to preemptively start pushing
the pawns which is I think the most
challenging and of course our opponent
plays it
now we have to decide whether we're
slowing white down or whether we're
pushing and these are very hard
decisions to make
that require tremendous calculation
so there's King D5 there there
it's a weird construction but in my view
what we need
okay let's go King D5
let's go King C5
of course it is possible and now Rook H5
this is the construction that I came up
with this actually might be a genius
idea look at this Rook it's doing three
things it's guarding H4 and F5 and it's
preventing White's King from
infiltrating further so it's keeping the
king at Bay and is keeping the Rook at
Bay indirectly because anytime The Rook
moves our pawn moves forward
but I'm delegating to my king a very
important responsibility I'm basically
leaving the King on its own
and our King's job is going to be
twofold I mean first of all it not only
has to keep White's Pawn majority
restrained that's not enough remember
our ultimate goal here which is to
essentially inducevang and force white
to move this Rook away from H3 so that
we can start pushing our h-pod
how are we going to induce that scenario
where we'll get we're going to basically
try to freeze White's Pawn majority and
we've already come very very close to
achieving that because B5 is impossible
because if King takes C5
so why can push the a pawn well we can
basically wait it out after A4 we can
play A6
and then if white plays A5 then he
basically deep freezes his own Pawn
majority and then we've clearly
succeeded right
so the only other option is for white to
drop the king back clearly that
signifies progress and then we can use
our own King to infiltrate and start
posing threats against White's Pawn
majority White's ability to defend those
pawns is restrained greatly by the fact
that his Rook can't move so here I think
it's important not to play King C4 but
to basically wait it out with the move
A6
and only when white plays A4 do we
infiltrate with the King what was the
downside okay we need to focus
I don't see Kings 47 h3o b7h2 wins I
think our opponent is trying to Bluff oh
but now I think we need to okay so how
do we do this A5 is possible
A5 might be winning on the spot here let
me calculate
A5 ba can you take C5 King E5
King B5 King D6 King takes A5 King C7
Rook H7
uh
alternatively we can play King D4 first
we can play King D4 first
and only when white plays King F3 do we
play A5
that is possible
but I don't think it's necessary
A5 C6 BC
ba King B5 I think we should play A5
here
I think we should play A5 here
I mean this is this is basically tempo
for Tempo it might be a draw
but if white draws this listen I'm
tipping I'm happy to tip my hat because
I am doing everything within my power
for us to win this game
now the basic idea here to understand is
that again anytime White's Rook moves
unless white moves away with a check
then we automatically push H3 and
because of the placement of White's King
it we've we've created a situation where
the king is incapable of getting behind
the pawn it's always going to be one
tempo short so we don't have to worry
about a scenario where white moves The
Rook away and then gets the king to H2
because that's not possible
mathematically if the Rook moves we go
H3 King G3 H2 and the plot squeezes
through
it's also very important for us to keep
this B7 Pawn alive at all costs this is
a harder point to understand
now why do I say that because if white
is able to liquidate all of the queen
side pawns then our King side pawns even
if there's two of them might not be
enough for us to win because our King
presumably would be a little bit too far
away from the King say that would still
be very close but that might conceivably
be a draw
no this is a very interesting game
actually I think this is going to be a
worthy speedrun game after a long
absence but our work is not done in 20
seconds got 20 seconds gotta play Fast
here
but I I really you should notice how
incredibly powerful this Rook is on H5
it's doing everything
and so if we win this game then a big
part of it would have been our ability
to find good squares for the Rook at the
right time
so what is our next move right
especially when you're in time pressure
you should have a road map in mind so
against a waiting move like King E3 like
what's our next move going to be well
it's probably going to be king B5 if
white plays A4 then of course we play
King before so our next step is to
eliminate the A5 Pawn that's the low
hanging fruit
now what's crazy is that white could say
okay I'm going to give up the A5 pawn
and white to H3 Rook is also on a very
good spot because it's defending the
other a pawn making it hard for us to
win it and
and it's essentially keeping blacks King
at Bay and not allowing us to infiltrate
through the backside
so we're gonna have to do some
maneuvering there and and figure out a
way to maybe sacrifice one of these
Pawns in order to win the a pawn that's
all going to be really tough in time
pressure but white is now down to two
and a half minutes so finally our
opponent is feeling the heat on the
clock here
in E5 which is exactly what I expected
oh
our opponent found a brilliant idea this
might drop
you can be five
but maybe not
so we we do what we have to do there's
King app six my goodness this guy
King F6 and King G6 like this
the thing is white will win one of the
king side pawns but he might not be in
he might not be in time no he goes A6
okay wait
or what do we take with
believe it or not I'm very much inclined
to take with the King because in general
in such positions you want to have the
beep on the corner Pawn is often a
serious weakness
on the other hand ba might be good
because then we'll be able to play King
A4 but okay I think he's collapsing here
but he's making me prove it on the clock
picking A5 let's Advance our King now
our next Target position is to play B5
and King A4 our opponent misses the best
defense there which was King F6
now again the golden rule of this end
game is that we're keeping our King
specifically on the a file so that the
Rook is unable to move away with check
that's the thing our next move is likely
to be B5 why are we advancing the plot
well we are preparing for a scenario
that I'm kind of predicting will
eventually come which is a scenario
these pawns are not likely to win the
game because they're being restrained in
order to win the game we will ultimately
have to win the A3 Pawn to win the A3
Pawn we might have to part ways with
either the F1 or the H Pawn we're going
to have to do it very strategically not
just randomly but the first step in
anything is to get our King to A4 so
that it's making contact with this pawn
and then the second logical step is to
shift the B Pawn up to B5 preparing for
the scenario where when we win the A3
Pawn because then this Pawn is going to
be closer to promotion you also do this
in a lot of Pawn end games
um and it's a very very important
technique there we go there's B5
there's B5
and we might have just gotten zogged
King have four words I should have
played B6 that would have been more
subtle
but I think we'll figure it out here
I it's winning it's winning
I think I know how and it's going to be
very close
no I'll show you I figured out a way
I figured I think I figured out the one
thing is with increment we have to be
very careful because if we mess it up
like white will have enough time to hold
but I think I was able to figure out the
win here
okay of course he plays it now we have
to sack the pawn
now we have to sack the pawn now here
here
that might be a draw can also go Rook E8
and try to cut the king that's the thing
we have to cut this king off and prevent
it from reaching the queen side
so maybe this idea comes through
has to sit yeah let's go rookie eight
let's go rookie eight no definitely not
B4 that would be the worst move in the
position we again what I've predicted
has come true we have to cling to this
Pawn at all cost if we lose the B Pawn
we draw the game
now if white takes H4 this is an easy
win because it's basically a Lucina
position on okay Laura Upon A collapses
this is an easy win this was already
lost because eventually we would have
gotten to that pawn now it's quite easy
we just push our pawn and this is like a
standard Lucina but it's it you don't
even need the Lucina position here
because the king is so far away from the
pawn the Lucina is required when the
king is two files closer when the king
is this cut off you know you know you
could you can win this in a million
different ways and the easiest notice
what I'm doing here I'm bringing the
pawn as close as it's possible to bring
it to the king now where newer players
struggle is they always try to move away
from the pawn because intuitively you
might say well I don't want to step in
front of the pawn because I don't want
to block its path to the promotion
Square the problem is that if you play
King to D2 here white can keep checking
you and white can shift The Rook back to
the B file and constantly attack this
Pawn that's a drawing technique in a lot
of end games so you do step in front of
the pawn but you do it so that the pawn
can reach the second Rank and now the
final stage of the conversion process
again you don't need to build a bridge
or anything like that there's a much
simpler way to win the game when the
king is this cut off who knows what the
easiest technique to Winning is to
finish it off rookie two yeah it's
possible but even simpler is actually
just to play Rook to A8 and you can also
play Rook to C8 it's the same exact
concept and that's it now you move the
king over to A1 and the reason you
needed that move is to prevent this
check on A5 which would have sent our
King right back to B1 as it stands
White's king is too far away we promote
to a queen and we win the game oh that
was a tough one
that was a tough one
a lot of stages to that game and I
definitely had my sloppy moments but I
thought I played the end game very well
of course the computer is probably gonna
laugh at me
okay let's I'm gonna I'm curious about
the accuracy
I want to be laughed at
yeah and there's a lot to talk about so
well a lot we have to unpack here
90.5 to 86.1 high level game
I will be using stockfish on my chess
base for uh
some analysis I'm just going to copy
this game over to chess base I also use
that for opening analysis
all right so let's delve write it the
marozzi bind characterized by the move
C4
named after jeza marozzi was a Hungarian
player I think lives in the 19th century
maybe to the early 20th was a very
strong player but really was the first
to develop this line and I would say at
a Grand Master Level the marozzi bind is
the biggest reason why the accelerated
Dragon isn't more popular now there are
two reasons why at lower levels this is
not a particularly scary line the first
is that it requires white to play
positionally very positionally and the
second is that black has a lot of tricky
responses to the morosi which most
players really under 2200 or so do not
know and if white doesn't know them then
White Center can collapse white is
biting off a very big part of the cake
and if white does not develop very
artfully many is the scenario where you
develop your pieces in white just
totally collapses in the center in fact
this is what happens in most games
featuring intermediate players where
black is well versed in a tricky
accelerated lines so to get to the point
Knight F6 is tricky and we've already
played this once I think and in that
game our opponent immediately fell into
the first trap which is to take on C6
and to play E5 this is a very tempting
move
but anytime you have this situation you
have to of course remember that we have
Queen A5 check
so don't forget this trap this is super
important and of course we pick up the
pawn E5 and here black is simply a
healthy pot up and then we go Bishop G7
and we castle and we can easily Advance
D5 the queen can always drop back to
this envelope on C7 it's also common in
the scandi so we can chill on E5 but
then when white plays
for instance rookie one we don't have to
but an easy way to guarantee safety is
to play Quincy sup
so that doesn't work now if white takes
and then goes Knight C3 then as I've
explained many times before this trade
favors black this C6 Pawn is now a great
positional asset because it's holding
this Knight in May and we've got this
semi-open B file and this is just a very
comfortable position for black as well
so the main roof here is Knight to C3 F3
I think is already a serious inaccuracy
and I will check the best way to fight
against it I've never analyzed F3 so I
you know maybe Knight 64 is is an
inaccuracy in response
um so Knight C3 my recommended line is
Knight takes D4 Queen takes C4 now not
Bishop G7 because here E5 is very
dangerous but instead you have to
remember to play D6
super super tricky sideline now to
explain why it's a tricky sideline first
of all the sort of important thing to
understand is that E5 is no longer
dangerous because after we take on E5
white can take on d8 yes we lose
castling rights but the reality is that
uh White does not Garner sufficient
compensation for the plot and you should
remember in such positions I know I make
fun of that phrase I'm going to verify
this with the engine
what a lot of people are afraid of in
these types of situations is you know
let's say a move like Bishop to E3 and
then oh well White's gonna Castle Queen
side and it's gonna be a check but
that's just not that dangerous that
engine move here in fact is just to
ignore everything and hit the bishop
with Knight G4 and big deal White
Castle's Queen said you block with a
bishop yeah you're self-pinning but
white is no way to put pressure on this
bishop
you might say well what about this move
threatening Bishop B5 again you should
not be afraid particularly at this level
of one move threats they're not
dangerous after Knight takes c3f take C3
the engine finds a brilliant way to
defend against the thread Bishop H6 is
possible and who can tell me if you're
watching on YouTube pause and figure
this out why does Bishop B5 not win a
piece easy but very pretty
thank you once America Marty Wolfman for
the subs
yeah Bishop takes E3 check the bishop
drops like to D4 and intercepts The Rook
incredible
and black emerges two with two extra
parts now apparently this position is
still equal but white has to play this
like an engine practically speaking I
think black is doing great here
oh the more common move is going to be
Queen takes C5 but again obviously this
is very good for black because the
center has opened White's got weaknesses
on the D file the queen is now very
vulnerable and our next move is going to
be Castle so this doesn't even you can
basically play this without analysis but
to give you an in a sample line and
there's no question that Queen takes
Queen is a better move than Queen takes
C5 if white plays Bishop B2 we Castle
White Castles and one important point
about playing these types of accelerated
positions as we did in the game is not
to rush to try to give a discovered
attack to the queen so a lot of you
might be tempted by a move like Knight
G4 again this is one move it is it's not
a move is not strong because it poses a
threat in fact it helps the queen get
back to a safer Square
and if you get too obsessed with this
you're gonna end up paying the price for
you know these myopic moves
so instead in the spirit of what we did
in the game the best move is Bishop to
E6 again just developing the bishop and
actually this now poses a threat of a
discovered attack so if white sleeps
through this moment then we have this
very powerful move Knight to D5 and
we're able to take on C3 or even to
Garner the bishop pair with Knight takes
C3 if white plays Rook D1 again it's
just a one move threat we can still play
Knight D5 which is a Brazen looking move
but we hit the queen and the point is
that after Queen G3 we can solve our
problems tactically with Knight takes
Knight
and if white plays Rook takes T8 then
Knight takes C2 check picks up the queen
and then picks up the Rook
um of course white has to play BC and we
developed the Queens A5 and black is
much better so you can dig around here
on your own if you want to a fuller
understanding you're not gonna face the
movie five that often though
why does many setups here and I can
spend an hour just talking about the
theory of this line but let me show you
what happens in most games at sort of
the lower levels I can check Lee chess
for the most common move
but most people they basically just
develop their pieces they play Bishop E2
when I face this line with white for the
first time this is also what I did
Bishop B2 and Bishop B3 is a super
common setup it's not bad I mean it's
one of the main lines but it's not the
most ambitious either
now after castles we reach the first
important moment a lot of people Castle
here black is already better what should
black do who can tell me after White
Castles you should not be looking for a
tactic here you should be looking for a
positionally improving trade
not Knight D7
not B6
so I've scared you away from delivering
discovered attacks but here you do have
a good discovered attack Knight G4 why
well because we're able to pick off the
bishop why does that benefit black what
benefits black pretty intuitive are
because now we have this uncontested
dark squared bishop and look at how weak
white Stark squared Bishops are
hopefully you're already gaining enough
of an understanding to know what the
next move is likely to be where does the
bishop on C8 belong well it belongs on
E6 hitting the C4 plot
now let's say the white plays a move
like B3 well now we have actually a very
powerful move Queen to B6 which is
another sexy idea very sexy idea and in
the event of the queen trade we open up
the a file and we have an attack on C3
let's say white defends now we can play
even the move B5 which really shows you
the power of the accelerated when it
fires on all cylinders of course it's a
pretty Cooperative line but here I can
essentially resign because he's losing
material
right so it's this it's this power of
the Bishops
um and definitely white has to move the
queen for that reason so Queen D2 is the
main move and the best move you know
once you have your feet under you the
moves become quite easy here you play
Bishop B6
and develop your bishop and most people
in this position of course they Castle
Kingston if white analyzes this with an
engine then he can potentially play
better now there are several moves in
this position that you can try but the
main move is Queen to A5 you basically
bring the queen out and put more
pressure on White's Queen side and I
claim that this position is very very
hard to play for white if he's not very
well versed in the theory
so a couple of examples to illustrate
how dangerous this can be a lot of
people get very tempted by this tactic
Knight D5 which was a common tactic but
it doesn't work here because after the
take trade on D2 white takes on E7
Intermezzo but the line doesn't end here
black plays Knight takes C4 and develops
a huge initiative the Knight is stranded
everything's hanging this is better for
black
so that's one line to remember
now if white plays B3 because a lot of
people are tempted to reinforce the C4
Pawn B3 is a good move
and black has a couple of options here
but the best is to play Rook F to C8
again let's say white plays a move like
F3 and sleepwalks through this moment
well already black develops a huge
initiative on the queen Side by playing
A6 what are we preparing we're preparing
the move B5 why is that move dangerous
because after B5 white is unable to take
because the Knight on C3 hangs so let's
say white says okay well I'm gonna go
Rook C1 and I'm gonna defend this Knight
Well turns out the black and still very
often play B5 because after a cbaby
white collapses on the queen side if
Bishop takes B5 who can tell me the
simple and very powerful move that makes
this line work
this is part of the big reason that you
put your Rook on C8
of course Rook takes Knight
and as I've explained many times
um two pieces for a rook usually
benefits the minor pieces particularly
in the middle game with a wide open
Center
um by the way after Rook to AC3 we also
have the move Knights AC4 which is even
sexier than Queen takes B5 because we
recapture the rook and everything starts
hanging you can
analyze this a little bit more on on
your own and if white plays Knight takes
B5 then of course we take the queen
if white plays Rook takes CA check we
can do either Rook takes hit or even
Bishop take C8 and we recapture on A2
with a huge initiative and the end game
after Rook D1 we can redeploy the bishop
on E6 and start tickling this Pawn white
is getting tortured here
so that's yet another line now of course
white can play A4 and defend against B5
now you should not play B5 because of a
b with a discovered attack on the queen
but anytime A4 is played in The
Accelerated Dragon you should understand
that the B3 Pawn becomes a permanent
weakness what are the tools available to
us to attack it well one thing we can do
is just stick the queen on this weak
Square
white is forced to defend the pawn but
here you have to remember the maneuver
Knight F6 to D7 some of you were
suggesting this move earlier here it's
actually very strong because it opens up
an attack on the Knight and the Knight
potentially dives into C5 and also after
Rook fc1 we can now play B5
a b a b
and
if CB then we win the Knight
and if Knight takes B5 who can tell me
what is the correct sequence from this
position
this will test if you understand kind of
the idea of B5 I'll be right there
what's the move here
very good you got it
now the key thing to understand is that
very often when you sack upon you should
not rule out a queen trade Queen tree
doesn't mean anything this skewers the
Bishops now after Rook D1
it's time to start a fire on the other
side of the board
we have white very much compromised but
in order to trans
you know to to translate that to an
actual Advantage we have to continually
create threats and challenge white where
he's weak and in order to do that we
often have to use our Pawn so this is
another very typical accelerated Dragon
idea a very timely use of the move F7 F5
what is the point of this move well if
white takes on F5 then you play Bishop
F5 Rook C1 and you can go either Bishop
B2 to trap The Rook or Knight to C5 when
white is no good way to defend me
through just look at the extent of
Black's domination here
and I might say well I don't understand
like what if white ignores martial it's
not that easy to make a move here
because white is so paralyzed
but let's say white literally plays H3
well now we can play Knight C5 and we're
already attacking the E4 pawn and white
starts to collapse here white can play
B4 to chase the Knight away but now the
Knight squeezes into A4 and now c4 is
weak and white can't move this rope
because the bishop hangs so much like
the grunefeld The Accelerated is about
appreciating the power of Peace activity
and the ability to sacrifice sometimes
upon sometimes even more than that to
achieve this long-term activity and to
understand that it's not all about when
you sacrifice something it's not like
you have to win immediately right or win
in two or three moves you can play for a
very prolonged period of time let's say
down upon even down a piece as long as
your other pieces are active this is the
concept of squeezing and putting
pressure which is very challenging but
it's why I'm talking about it because
we're at a high level now
okay so that was a lot
now
there are many more lines to show here I
will point out that I don't remember
what the uh what Wesley's recommendation
is in his E4 course like you guys can
tell me but the main line Bishop 7 is
Bishop E3 the line that used to be
considered best is actually Bishop C1 to
G5 at one point I think this was
considered to be a very good line
here in contrast of course black has no
good Discovery because this bishop is
invulnerable
but our strategy barely changes we still
play Bishop E6 we're still threatening
Knight D5 so white is now forced to drop
back to D2
and now we play Queen A5 once again we
basically make the same moves against
everything
and another very important thing to
understand is that very often white
plays Bishop H6 in these types of
positions and this is a bad move
and the reason why is that you do give
up your fiancado Bishop but look at how
weak these pawns are the simplest way to
pick them off is to play Rook AC 8. and
white can't play B3 very common blunder
at a lower level even some GM supported
like this against me white can play
Knight D5 and hit E7 but after Bishop
takes D5 if white takes with a c Pawn
the E Pawn drops and if white takes to
the E Pawn this is another classic
scenario this is a pawn chain how do we
attack this punch and well you already
know that B5 is one of Black's main
tools on the queen side and after C
takes B5 you can take this Pawn or you
can put the emphasis on piece activity
and infiltrate to C2 black is the only
one having fun
so
um Kings Gambit asks what if white
pushes F4 F4 does not create a threat
and so we can simply continue with our
campaign and play Rook AC and after B3
you guys should already understand what
Black's move is right when B3 is played
the first thing you should always test
is whether you can play the immediate B5
and here you can
because the queen on D2 is hanging right
the move F4 has severed the connection
between the bishop and the queen making
B5 possible
so there are so many of these lines that
I can show you but I think that's enough
for now this is like a good introduction
to this line I'm sure that we're gonna
have another game when we're 2200 or so
and then I'll talk more about Theory
yeah Knight takes C4 was not possible
and the reason is sorry I just wanted to
address
this question so we were talking about
this line Castle's castles Bishop B6
Queen E2
Queen A5 F4 Rook AC 8 B3 Knight take C4
is bad because white takes on e4
and When the Smoke Clears white has two
pieces for a rook no black is all right
here but this is nothing to write home
about really nothing to write home about
because Black's Rooks are also very very
bad there are no open files to control
and then you might say well but two
pieces for Rook how do I understand
who's better that's one of those things
that that is decided on a case-by-case
basis it's an imbalance and that is why
one of the biggest pieces of advice
given to higher rated players is to seek
positions with a lot of imbalances
because they are harder for a lower
rated player to evaluate because they
require a lot of experience and
understanding to evaluate properly
okay so you shouldn't be thinking of
this in the terms of oh what is the
formula for evaluating this two pieces
for a rook is generally good for the two
pieces so most of the time you should
have a good justification for going for
it if you are the side of the Rook
okay hopefully that was halfway sensible
again I'll talk more Theory later let's
address our opponent's move F3 I'm going
to check this with the engine of course
F3 has been played many many times
oh so there's some tactics here that are
interesting
yeah so apparently but Knight takes D4
is all right but not the best move
the best move according to the engine is
indeed Bishop G7
white plays Bishop E3
and here we have to rely on a
well on a trap it I mean in order to
understand this move you have to know
the most famous accelerated dragon trap
which I've shown before we've actually
already had it that trap occurs when
white basically tries to play it like a
regular Dragon when white plays the move
Bishop C4 we castle and white basically
tries to make all the moves that he
would make in a dragon who remembers
what the punishment is against this line
what's the famous trap that Bobby
Fischer fell into against Oscar Pano
it's not Knight takes C4 that blood is a
piece but you want to set that move up
with a very counter-intuitive move and
that counter-intuitive move is Queen to
B6 and the whole point is that the
bishop on E3 is undefended so white
would normally be able to do something
like this here of course White's not
able to do that now the common response
is Knight F5 but now we grab this plot
on B2 and black wins the game
and the reason why Let me refresh
because I got disconnected one sec sorry
and the reason why
and this is important I know this is a
little bit tedious you might be yawning
if you're watching on YouTube but you
know you you have to build the
foundations of opening knowledge there's
just no way around it
so Knight F5 Queen B2 hits the Knight on
C3 and not only that we're also going to
win one of the Bishops so white loses a
bunch of pieces here
if white plays something like Bishop to
B3 sorry if white plays something like
Bishop to B3 to defend the pawn now
you're able to play Knight takes C4 this
looks very confusing but in fact it's
very easy to understand you now have
three attackers on this Knight and only
two Defenders once again this Knight is
very limited in its scope because the
bishop on E3 is going to drop
if white plays Knight F5 then we can
play Knight takes C3 and hit the queen
and in this way we Evacuate the Knight
that's hanging and if white plays Fe
then we play Bishop takes D4
specifically Bishop takes to not
self-pin
and we're good we're fine takes we take
with the queen and we're simply up a pot
so you can invest it white can equalize
here but it's very hard
well I mean Fisher figured it out
against quano
so having with this idea under your bell
it should be easier to understand what
the move is here again it's this queen
B6 idea now here it's even more
complicated because now Knight F5 looks
quite a bit scarier the bishop on G7
drops with check but he did fall into
the truck but then Fisher was able to
equalize
if you calculate further you will notice
that we quickly win the piece back
because this Knight is trapped and The
Rook is hanging so this move
is not scary because white has no good
Discovery this is a double check big
deal we just go King G and we win
it's scary but if you know that this is
the move then it's easy white has to
defend the Rook then we take on G7
and black is up a pawn here
um
and I think practically this is a very
hard position for white to play because
if white plays a move like Bishop to E2
which I think is The Logical move then
we stick the Knight right in White's
Grill Knight T4 we're threatening a fork
right and if white just ignores and
castles then we actually can get away
with Knight C2 because after Rook to B1
who can tell me what the key resource is
for black and this is kind of a theme in
these lines
yeah it's simple right Knight takes C3
and we take and hit the queen at the
same time don't forget about these moves
and the key is not to automatically
assume oh I have to move my queen you
have to look for moves that let's say
take a piece and simultaneously attack
your opponent's piece and that When the
Smoke Clears black is simply up upon and
white is no position either
okay so hopefully that line made sense
there's a lot more to this the only
other thing I point out the second most
common move here is Queen to D2 and
again you should already be able to tell
what's wrong with Queen D2 this walks
right into the Trap Knight takes C4
if white plays Let's test your guys's
attention if white takes the Knight on
C6 should black play Knight takes queen
or queen takes Knight which move
try to calculate
yeah Knight takes Queen is the correct
move
because after white takes Our Queen We
simply play a B material is equal and we
are attacking White's Knight so When the
Smoke Clears were just up upon and we've
got a dominant mission
so Queen takes Knight would be a
horrible blunder because it would simply
give away the Knight on e4
yeah there are other moves there but I'm
showing the simplest approach
what else is there of course if white
plays Fe then again we play Bishop takes
D4
Bishop takes D4 Queen takes D4 and of
course the end game is
simply miserable for white
okay
so that would have been the correct
approach it would be simply to play
Bishop G7
and in response to Bishop E3 to play
Queen B6 white can also play Knight C3
here
white can also play Knight C3 here
but here black wins with the tactic who
spots it and actually not a lot of
people have found this tactic I see that
a a 2000 fell into this in 2021 in a
classical game
it's not castles
it's not Knight takes D4 that bonus a
piece it is Knight takes C4 great job
Colin
same idea now a lot of people when they
see this movie well doesn't work white
takes this Knight then we have to take
back and we lose a piece again don't
forget about this concept we take
whitesnite and threaten the queen
simultaneously okay that's the key
white takes Our Queen we take whites
Queen
now white can win the pawn back here
with a Desperado Knight takes F7 but
even though I wins the pawn back this
end game is still horrible for white
look at how passive white is look at how
bad these Bishops are look at our Bishop
and we're gonna pile up on the C4 Pawn
on the next move with Bishop E6 and Rook
ACA which is an idea that by now should
be very familiar too
of course if white plays Rook B1 then we
can chase The Rook away with Bishop F5
and then drop back to E6
this placement of the bishop is crucial
okay
so instead we took on T4 and played
Bishop G7 probably E5 is not the best
though I can do my guess is that white
should have reverted back to probably
like a main line with Knight to C3 then
we would have castled and we would have
gotten something very similar to kind of
the main line anyways let's focus on E5
because it's already been a while
Knight G8 Knight C3
okay this is all very natural and here
we sort of came to the first Crossroads
uh in the game where
initially of course I was banking on D
take C5 that is the engine's Top Choice
but still I'm not a huge fan of this
position the engine simply says hey
bishop D7 big deal we're up a pawn
evaluation here is equal white has
enough compensation for the pawn but not
more than that
and if white plays it accurately then
white is worse so I thought white would
go here according to the engine white is
supposed to drop back to E3 just to keep
this diagonal under control
and here the engine's top move is
actually Bishop to H6 so you trade off a
pair of Bishops
and simultaneously you get your knight
out of the gate and then I can circle
around through F5
now white is supposed to play this very
typical move C5
in order to threaten Bishop B5
and one way that the game could bail out
is uh well we can play Knight F5 but
that's iffy best is to play King E8
and it's important to understand that in
this situation Knight D5 is no longer
dangerous because we can simply bring
the Rook to C8
but if you contrast that
to this situation because of the
presence of this bishop Knight D5 is now
a whole lot more dangerous because it's
not easy to defend the C7 Square in fact
here black kids Jack method with Rook d8
so this would not be fun
so perhaps we should have played de I
decided to keep the tension the engine
also likes this move
so Queen E4
and now this was a very important
Crossroads because we decided
essentially to bail out with Pawn take
C5 which of course is fine
I'm gonna check the engine here and then
I won't over align the engine I promise
you that
okay so looks like we did have Queen B6
oh
oh this is really interesting
yeah this is very high level very high
level the best move is Queen B6 Pawn
takes E5 and what we did is second best
that's just equal
black is the slight Edge Apparently
after Queen V6 now who can remind me why
did I reject this move and why does this
move look like it plays into White's
hands what does it allow white to do
you don't have to remember all this
folks if you're trying to remember all
of this you're doing it wrong first of
all this will be up on YouTube
and you can review it as often as you'd
like you have to try to understand the
ideas which hopefully I'm doing a
halfway decent job of explaining long
Castle
no come on 95 maybe but we can just
chase the night away here with A6
so no it's log Castle now the engine
gives this idea d Bishop B5
and Bishop H6 check
already setting a trap if the king moves
the side then Bishop F5 pins the queen
white has to play F4 and intercept now
we bring our Knight out with tempo and
white is in some trouble here because
the queen has no good squares
white can go into the end game with
Queen D4 or Y can trade on F6 and go
Knight T5 and this is right when you
analyze the engine like when you have
this position without engine it would be
terrifying looks like white has some
Discovery and our King is in the center
when you look at the engine eval you
realize that white has absolutely
nothing because on the next move you
just Castle
and you've got two fantastic Bishops
white king is in permanent trouble and
again in such positions white is always
having a hard time finding a good spot
for this bishop because of this darn C4
Pawn then if white plays C5 then we can
castle and we can actually start
targeting this Pawn with Rook A8 to see
it so whatever white does there will be
some downside
so this is this is high level stuff for
sure we decided to play it in a much
simpler way with uh Bishop takes E5 now
let's say the position is equal
and H4 was a very interesting idea by
our opponent followed by H5 and in this
position white has a force draw this is
like the last thing I'll ask you guys to
find because once we got into the end
game and we entered the technical phase
of the game we're gonna go a lot faster
and we're just going to kind of focus on
just a couple of the important moments
we're not going to look at every move
but white did have a draw here and I
deliberately avoided saying this on
stream just in case it is Rook takes H5
but what's the actual draw here this is
hard to see
and this reminds me of something yeah
Queen G3 or queen G5
and you go back to E5
and this reminds me of something
and the bishop hangs now maybe I would
have played this move but there's no
question the white is better here right
our Pawn structure was ruined a rook's
coming to D1 the bishop could come to D3
and create made threats against this
Pawn this is miserable so I would have
had to objectively take the draw
now this is a very important type of
tactic which occurs in in a different
version I've seen this tactic many times
let me let me search up a sample to help
you understand
what I'm talking about
let me see if I can quickly and
efficiently
find an example
so it's a tactic that relates
specifically to scenarios where the
bishop is on E6 which happens quite
often because E6 is a standard
developing score for the bishop this is
just some game
between two two thousands
and white finds the following idea white
plays Rook a to E1
forcing the bishop on E6 and now white
finds a very powerful move I think a lot
of you would be very tempted to take
this one but this Cashes in too soon
because black moves the rook and black
is holding on white plays Queen E3 very
powerful move and black is powerless
black tries to get the queen out of the
pin and the key queen E5 threatening
mate and in order to defend against the
mate black has to push the f-bond which
relinquishes control over the bishop
okay and that's the general gist of of
what I'm talking about now let's go back
to the game
yeah so same concept right you give that
check and in order to defend against the
check you have to relinquish the control
over the bishop
something very similar could happen in a
scenario by the way like this where
again you're threatening mate to defend
against mate you have to give up money
so what is the takeaway from this the
takeaway is that when you're looking at
attacking ideas you should not forget
that one of the most powerful techniques
involves combining a made threat with a
threat on an undefended piece yet
another type of instantiation is a
scenario where I'm just getting a random
position a scenario like
I don't know like this one right very
often people forget that in such a
situation you can play Queen H6 and you
can attack both the undefended rook and
the H7 Pawn so there's a common
attacking technique which essentially
involves in a situation like this to
deliver a check first then to play Queen
H6 and Fork The Rook in the pawn rather
than going Queen H6 immediately which
doesn't attack The Rook
now hopefully that gives you a good good
little in tactically that's what our
opponent missed that is how close he was
to making a draw with Rook takes H5
instead he played the obvious movement
after Queen B8 we essentially Force the
queen trade because of the possibility
of diving into G3 and okay we could
spend another hour analyzing this end
game I think the next stage was pretty
straightforward we pair of Rooks were
traded we activated our Knight we moved
the Knight back to F5
we got this Knight versus Bishop
imbalance we dropped the bishop back to
E6 now we traded on the US there's a
bunch of Trades and we found this very
important move King f8 this was a
critical move right so you shouldn't be
unquestioningly afraid of The Rook
infiltration to the seventh ring because
sometimes you can do this thing where
you drive The Rook out using your rook
and your king
and then we're chilling
um
no it was not roshevsky Fisher it was in
fact fish for Pono
um it was Fisher Bono
okay
so there was a question why not E5 ah so
there's an interesting suggestion by
amaraldo why not to play E5 first I
didn't see this move honestly this is
actually a top bat well I saw this but I
rejected it because of Rook D5 but on
second thought you can actually go
Bishop E6 now and trade e uh Pawn for C
Pawn
yeah but okay but it's not like E5 helps
black that much in fact I would make the
argument that it seriously weakens the
D5 square right because now you can't go
E6 now you might say well here you're
blocking the epon but we still reserve
the possibility of playing E6 later down
the line it's a it's a minor detail
okay so King D2
we're placing it obviously we set up the
threat of rook d8 and here I actually
think that white makes a subtle mistake
I think that white should have tried the
move G5 I think this is the best
practical defense is to play G5 and I
have no idea whether black is in fact
winning in this pawn and given sometimes
even engines take a long time to
evaluate stuff like this I'm going to
check I'm going to check with the engine
here
and see if this end game is winning for
black
drum roll please
wow it's actually currently at equals
over plus no it's drop
it's a draw
and here's how I draw us
now this is all this is fascinating
what do you think White's best move is
here white as an only move apparently
and only moves to draw
yeah everything else loses
wow this is amazing
not C5
C5 loses B4 loses F4 only move is F4
now this is insanely hard what would be
my intuitive move my intuition would be
just to bring the king up to E3 the
reason this draws here black has this
crazy tactical idea you start with the
move that should be very obvious to all
of you you're trying to counteract the
Deep Freeze by removing the G5 obviously
White's gonna go F4 and here there's a
crazy tactic that wins this is a very
hard move
here white is a winning move or black is
a winning move brother that winning move
is to play E5 absolutely Brazen you're
like you're allowing a passer on F6
and you might be like well in this
scenario is it white just going to
create another passer on the queen side
and then you're gonna get a trouser
situation black is winning in this
position
and in order to win it's now black OS to
find an only move
to win black has to play
prophylactically A5
stopping white from advancing the B Pawn
and as much as possible slowing down the
process of creating a pass Pawn on the
queen side because if white goes here
then we deep freeze white on the queen
side with A4 this is a technique I
outlined in my in-game video
so in order to counteract this white has
to waste the tempo on B3 what do we use
this Tempo to do well we use this Tempo
to make this Pawn harmless how do we do
that well of course by blockading with
our King white continues to try to
create a passer but we are just in type
King F7 it hits the pawn white has to
defend it white has to defend it and now
we send our Pawn forward
and we win by a Tempo takes takes H4
threatening H3 white has to move the
king back we take F6 and this is an easy
win
because if white plays C5 clearly white
is not white is too tempy away from
creating a queen
now if white goes the other way and
tries King to G5 the winning move is H6
check this is easier to understand
and this is a winning position for black
with a very simple we just go with the
King to the queen side
for instance after C5 the easiest way to
win is to go King E5 and then King D4
and white is way too far away
after King F5 though the winning move is
actually King to C3 it's not King takes
Pawn because then White's King makes it
back to the center in time
but here black is winning because we get
to the pawns first
no it's crazy it's absolutely crazy if
white plays B4 then we're able just to
take twice we take C5 and we get a
winning kicking upon him again
so it's crazy but this is winning
now we need to play A5 if we start by
playing King E8 we give white that extra
tempo
and white uses this Tempo to reach this
position right that we talked about but
here because White's Advanced his pawns
even further
and if we try King E5
what is White's drawing technique to
play B5 and C6 and forcibly get rid of
the b-pawn and this is the worst case
scenario in almost all pawn end games
that you're trying to win the quarter
pot is the worst spot that you can have
because even if you win the a pawn white
is just in time tempo for Tempo reaches
C2 and reaches a very well-known
theoretical draw
so
Insanity I mean the level of complex and
this is just the pawn end game so Rook
end games have their own complexity plus
you have to constantly evaluate the The
Rook trade and and often you get Pawn in
games that are even more complicated so
all of that to say that Rook d8 is
incorrect
oh sorry all of that to say not even
that that white has to play out for in
order to draw but what on Earth happens
if black plays F6 right isn't this the
same thing what does white use that
Tempo to do
well according to the engine well you
already have an Insight on this position
how should white ensure that the same
scenario does not happen white has to
play B4 this is what white gains by
starting with F4
and if black plays A5 here
and tries to prevent that from happening
then white plays B3 F6 and A3 and black
is just not in time here
you basically save a Tempo on King E3
which turns out to be an unnecessary
move this is one of those Pawn endings
where creating past pawns is more
important than bringing the king to the
center
so that's where white saves that Tempo
and if black tries to do the same thing
black actually runs the risk of losing
here in fact black is already lost
because of the trousers
why wins by playing simply C5 and then
B5 and C6 is a classic case of trousers
you try to stop one pawn and the other
Pawn promotes you try to stop that other
pawn and the second Pawn promotes now of
course the White's King is close enough
to Black's Pawn majority to keep it at
Bay for long enough for white to promote
his punts does that make sense
now of course here you should never
forget that if black black simply cannot
stop whites pawns because this is the
benefit of upon majority you can force
the door open right here you can play B5
and both sides have spent to Tempo so
neither side has gained anything
and so in this position black has to
play something like King to D7 the game
goes on but this is a draw white uses
his Pawn majority to prevent black from
making any progress
actually white gets the king into the
center and eventually you reach a
scenario where neither side can make
progress black can't make progress
because you can't get rid of the Deep
Freeze and you can never set this H1 in
motion
incredible stuff now all of that to say
that after G5 I maybe would have played
Rook d8 but according to the engine the
best move is Rook to C8
King D3 and now F6 basically to do the
same thing but keeping the Rooks on the
board which gives you more winning
chances and if white plays F4 then again
you play E5 so even in the Rook end game
this is a very powerful technique crazy
F takes E5 F takes G5 and black is
winning here apparently because of the
three pass Pawns
and wow this position is also winning
for black and the reason we played Rook
C8 is to keep white tie down to this
Pawn so King E4 isn't possible and these
three passers are gonna decide the game
okay mind-blowing stuff but I think
that's enough King C3 now we go E6 and
we Chase The Rook away The Rook swings
over to the B file again just to
reiterate if the Rook had gone to D1
it's very important in Rook end games to
not fall asleep on concrete details I
think a lot of people would play Rook D1
right here and forget about Rook H1
suddenly you lose the pawn so you have
to go King E7 you have to be alert and
attentive to these moments Rook hate and
if white tries to play G5 here you
already know what the winning technique
is what would we have done in the event
of G5
you should already understand what the
process for ending the Deep Freeze is F6
F4 and what's the move now and here it's
actually quite obvious that this move is
correct because it doesn't involve any
sacrifices
yeah it's E5 we literally just break
through that deep freeze
and after Fe
we play f g and the past pawns decide
the game and if GF here we don't even
need to sacrifice anything we simply get
this situation and again we have
connected passers they're just gonna
push on their own our Rook is ideally
placed
could you start with E5 before F6 yeah I
probably yeah you could you could you
could play E5 and then F6 the thing is
it is a waste of tempo though because
let's think about it mathematically the
good thing about starting with F6 is
that if white actually takes on F6
you've saved a Tempo on E5 which you
don't need to play now you can start
pushing your H Pawn
by playing E5 this is a minor subtlety
you're giving white an extra Tempo which
could become important because here
white is a little closer to creating a
past spawn of his own there's no need to
give white that Tempo you should only
play E5 in response to F4 does that make
sense
in fact inviting F4 is a good thing for
black because now we have two pass pawns
rather than one
okay so anyways minor points our
opponent decided to stay on the fifth
rank now we played H6 I think is a very
good move
oops sorry
King D4 King E7 bringing our King up and
preparing the eventual rook h8 and here
I decided to take the opportunity to
improve the placement of my Rook
okay F4 now I'm not gonna spend forever
analyzing this with an engine I think
it's sort of a 50 50 game and that maybe
white can draw this but practically
speaking it would be very difficult
I will point out where I think white
went wrong like White's big mistake
was probably in this position here I
think White had a drawing idea
and I'm actually going to confirm this
yes I just confirmed this with the
engine
I think this is a serious mistake and
here White had the same idea
without this idea why it loses it's a
tactical idea that generates counter
play on The Queen side very very
difficult let's see who can spot it I
will give you a hint there's something
that white can do on the queen side in
order to favorably transform the pawn
structure what is it
now way too slow way far a4a5a6 way too
slow black spot will be on H2 before you
blink not C6
to to too early you have to start with
Rook A5 but that's the right direction
why Rook A5 what does this do well this
attacks the a pod black plays A6 and now
we play C6 breaking apart the pawn chain
and in so doing white creates this
weakness that black now has to burn a
Tempo to defend but most importantly
white creates a past part of his own
that can be used as a bargaining chip
making it more difficult and giving The
Rook more tasks
so just a good like technique to have in
your library of ideas right you attack
upon force it forward and then you
overload the other pawn and I've seen
this kind of thing before
without this idea white just does not
have the defensive Firepower to keep
this Pawn at Bay maybe this is still a
draw miraculously but again I think it's
becoming harder and harder
and very importantly we we found the
right opportunity to play E5 we're
threatening to create a protected
password where the force the white ass
to take and already I think this is a
winning end game
King D5 I thought I played it very
accurately and this idea which I found
was I thought very very powerful this
Rook on H5
now you might say how did you know that
the Rook belongs there I actually had a
game but I remember correctly
where I had kind of a similar type of
idea
or basically the point is that you want
to extract the most benefit from your
rook in general in Rook end games
because you have so few pieces you want
your Rook to be playing to its fullest
potential and there was a game long ago
where I was able to save the game by
kind of following that rule of using the
Rook to perform and fulfill as many
tasks as possible I was able to draw a
GM in a game that I should should have
lost
so this is the position that I had
against that GM
now
it's a very difficult position for white
but I was able to find a very
interesting drawing technique
basically you ask yourself what does
black want
what black wants to do is to Simply
Advance this King forward I was able to
find a unique Fortress by playing E5
two concepts are at play here the first
is again I would call this using the
pawn as a bargaining chip where you
might be afraid of something like Rook
B5 but you don't have to because the
moment black takes the E Pawn With The
Rook we take the beep on it this is an
obvious draw black of course plays King
E6 Now The Rook switches over to E8 and
my opponent started to realize that he
can't make progress because if he drives
the king up The Rook drops down to E7
and you're able to win the F7 pawn and
then quickly run the king over to the
other side of the board
if white goes King D7 I threw in this
move and it'll go back to B8 and no
matter what black does any time the King
goes up to E6 The Rook temporarily moves
away from its ideal post to Chase the
king back down
and my opponent kept trying it he failed
and then my Rook was able to cut off the
king and eventually I was able to force
white to give this Pawn away and then
get my king to the right spot uh in
order to draw the game
why was E5 important here so let's say
you try to play this without E5 let's
say you go King F1 now maybe this is not
a great example oh it's I was afraid of
F6 there we go I was afraid of this move
and I think what you're able to see here
is that it's very hard for White's Rook
to do everything at once
if you go Rook at fade and try to do the
same thing Black's King basically
squeezes through
to a much more dangerous Square you're
basically trying to keep the king boxed
in it's not an ideal example but again
I'm just trying to help you understand
the bigger picture which is to try to
maximize the potential of each piece
particularly The Rook
and it doesn't always mean
you know a pre you shouldn't have a
preconceived notion of what an active
Rook looks like
um that's kind of the secondary concept
here
because you might look at this and say
well The Rook seems really passive
because it's quote-unquote tied down to
the protection of these funds well
that's one way of looking at it but it's
also tying white down
right because it signed down the king
it's keeping the king fully at May
notice how all of the infiltration
squares are protected and most
importantly it's keeping the Rook at Bay
anytime The Rook moves we push the pawn
now the last concept that I want to
highlight
is in this position
where I missed that white could actually
infiltrate from behind with King F6
and white could reach a very similar
position to the one in the game
but I still think black is winning and I
think we went in exactly the same way
that we won again we go B5 then we go
King A4 and then we give up the h-bond
for the B plot and we convert via the
Lucina method so go here here we go here
we go Rook C8 to cut off the king
and anytime white takes the pawn we take
on A3 this is a theoretical win this is
a Lucina position
so the king is just unable to make it to
the C file but I'll analyze this a
little bit more on my own this is
getting a little bit too high level for
all intents and purposes this is a
winning end game this is almost
impossible to save
um but I've I've bored you enough with
this end game our opponent gave up A6 I
took with the King notice what I did
here the reason I didn't take with a pun
is because having a corner Pawn often
hurts you in a lot of Rook end games and
one end games so even though it's
counter-intuitive to go backward I
thought the tempo was less essential
than keeping that B Pawn
which also immobilizes the a pawn with
the move B5
okay
so in any case we go B5 now we give up
one of the pawns strategically but we
cut off the king and last thing what if
White had avoided taking the uh H4 Pawn
well we could force white to take that
pawn with a move like Rook to G8
followed by Rook to G3 okay so white is
just not able to make it to the right
area of the board at the right time it's
just why it's just not in time we go B4
B3 B2 and notice how The Rook actually
cuts the king off along the third rank
so it's ideally placed on this Square
if white plays Rook takes H4 then you
kind of know the drill and the side
checks are easily parried by bringing
the king back to A4 and then blocking
with a pawn so the side checks are never
like it's never a Perpetual check here
because you basically use the same
technique again and again you go King A3
and then you go B3 and then King A2 and
B2 you should remember that technique of
dealing with side checks
and that's the basic uh premise for
winning this game now the way our
opponent played it the only thing you
have to know here is the technique of
putting the king behind the pawn in
order to advance the pawn one step
further essentially pulling yourself up
by the bootstraps and then finally no
listen I needed to just go Rook A8 you
choose the file that you will protect
and then you put the King on that file
and you promote the plot
and that uh concludes this very very
complicated game I basically only
scratched the surface of the end game
but we've been going well over an hour
and it's four I need to go to sleep
because we've got commentary today
technically it's already light outside
I hope you enjoyed any questions yeah
very very well played by our opponent so
big congratulations to our opponent I
mean last Speed Run game since I hit
2000 have been very I've been
legitimately hard
and I I mean this in to complement my
opponents
so really the the key takeaway in our
opponent played perfectly
and should have played Rook H5 and found
this draw
where I probably would have played F6
and risked it but I would have run the
risk of losing this game
yeah the big End Game book that I would
recommend is 100 end games you must know
I would recommend the chessable version
great introduction to like not only the
actual end games that you must know but
it also contains like great endgame
Essentials for like getting the hang of
a lot of positions
thank you everybody and I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]